The Golden Bowl's parking lot
didn't always look this great.
Just ask restaurant
consultant Marvin Wells.
The parking lot itself
was just a black top with faded stripes,
a wrought iron fence that
ran along the roadway.
but then a clear view of the trash bins
and the channel, which sits behind us.
None of it very appealing.
None of it appetizing at all.
Today it's got AstroTurf,
tiered levels, heat lamps,
shade covers, and a gardener.
It feels as relaxing as its surroundings
in Santa Monica Canyon.
It is actually the biggest
part of the restaurant
that we've had ever
we're busier than we've ever been.
But this is not a local news story
about a neighborhood steakhouse
repurposing it's parking lot.
It's a story about a city
that loosened its rules
during the pandemic
and unlocked a new world of possibilities
for how the entire city
could look and function.
And it all ties back to parking.
I think the government can
comfortably step back
from trying to dictate
how much parking every single
property owner provides
on their property,
and that in stepping back,
they will make cities more
efficient, more equitable,
and more environmentally sustainable.
Car ownership didn't start to become
the defining feature
of life in Los Angeles
until the 1920s.
The Los Angeles automobile ownership
actually started to explode
because this was actually a great place
to own a car
because of the mild weather and so forth.
Michael Manville is a
Professor of Urban Planning at UCLA
where he studies parking.
Well, what happened here is,
is what happened in a lot of places
when auto ownership started to grow,
which is that people would buy them,
but they didn't actually
have houses with garages
or driveways or off street parking.
And so most people would
park on the street.
And so the concern was that
as more people got cars
and as more people moved
to neighborhoods with cars,
the street parking would get congested.
And so the policy response
that seemed easiest
to solve that problem
was to pass a law saying that
whenever you built anything new,
you had to supply off street parking.
The city first imposed
minimum parking requirements in the 1930s.
By the 50's, they were
part of the zoning code,
not just of Los Angeles, but
of every major American city.
What they've done in Los Angeles,
because so much of the city
has been built since then,
is that they have quietly transformed
the entire city into a built environment,
oriented around owning
and operating automobiles.
Parking requirements for new buildings
were intended to prevent new residents
from competing for curb space.
What the planners didn't anticipate
is that they would make cars and parking
the defining characteristic
of the urban landscape.
Someone was going to build
a building on my street
and I was worried that
it was going to screw up
the parking on the curb
where I put my car.
And so we passed a law
and because of that law,
I got the building I wanted,
it had a parking lot next to it.
And then we kept doing that for 70 years
and everybody got the building they want,
and nobody got the city they wanted.
Parking lots and garages
proliferated in American cities.
And especially in Los Angeles
where the number of parking spaces
grew decade after decade,
the requirements were such
a big part of city life
that allowing developers
to build less parking
than required by the zoning code
became a bargaining chip
between city planners and developers.
And so the way this might work would be
developer has a plan
for an apartment building with 50 units
or something like that
and either through the State Government
or the local government strikes a deal
where the developer can take some
combination of extra density,
they can build more units,
reduce parking, some more height,
if for instance,
they set aside 15% of their units
as affordable housing
for lower income people.
This concern is misplaced.
We know that parking requirements
do a lot of damage.
But the way they encourage driving,
the way they reduce density,
reduce walk-ability, debase
the built environment,
undermine walking and so forth,
we shouldn't just keep them on the books
because occasionally we get some
affordable housing out of it.
Reducing unnecessary parking requirements
would allow all developers
to build more housing,
creating more supply
and reducing the cost
of housing for everyone.
When developers need a special arrangement
or variants to diverge from
the official zoning code,
rules aren't consistently applied.
Same goes for restaurant
commercial spaces.
Most restaurants in LA
don't have onsite parking
that satisfies zoning code.
The Taco Bells, the
McDonald's, the Sizzlers,
those are the ones that
satisfy parking code.
Mott Smith, whose company rents out
commercial kitchen space,
is also a member of
the Council of Infill Builders
and advocates for easing
parking requirements for restaurants.
Everybody else is either going
into a grandfathered space
or they're getting a variance.
And if you want to know
why food is expensive
and why it's hard for
restaurants to survive,
this is reason number one,
is that we make them comply
with these way outdated
parking requirements.